the thing is because it's only usual to
have two such young Oscar winners you
know this is normally something happens
later Fran yeah you gotta meet love but
the other thing you share is quite
short-lived careers in modeling oh yeah
Wow
happy new year so so because you now
what was your big break was it focus
choir I think all of it
talked about it or was it in fact one
actually no I think it's about to talk
about what I can feel caught in it yes
because he did you look at these like
it's hard to make a jumper sexy true
that but first I think
as role
as will ever look Potter I mean
seriously here's the thing sweater has
eyeballs I'm actually still buy that and
it's at the point of that is you can
learn to knit it yourself so you guys
can take one of those home and knit it
yourself so you can find a sweater and
then I have to do it myself
yeah actually there's a classic thing in
here so you know you want something of
Christmas and you say to like your mommy
your granny so I'd really like a really
trendy sweat top I'd like a really nice
trendy zippy upset top and then they
knit it for you that's the Christmas
nightmare yeah but you still do some
modeling don't you sporadically and very
unsuccessfully oh stop it you did what I
did do I did some um I did a campaign
for Burberry which was very amazing and
I did a few years ago and Mary Testino
shot it cool and I remember doing it was
when I was just starting out and they
were in this photograph there was a sort
of there was a model and me an actor
wannabe actor and a musician
and married to see know who I had never
worked with who is one of the most
extraordinary brilliant people but he's
just almost in that moment he was always
like I said a parody of himself so we
had to run and jump for the photograph
and he goes he's literally got the
camera there and he goes okay so
battling your supermodel your rock star
Eddie you movie star I marry have this
you know I wanted to go
these two sort of pros and me with this
show he gets the photos because they're
so natural ones of sort of shock and
minor despair and Wonder I think I'm
safer cuz you you don't have my picture
no I don't because I'll tell you why yes
tell us why cuz it really amazing job to
get a programming model yeah hey I've
got me a sighs gentlemen you know
don't make your hoots
please kill me a story after this so my
pictures never came out it did like the
whole campaign and the pictures never
came out and I didn't know why am i a
gent wrote and asked why and they
literally only responded with the photos
they like their home like idea was like
we want real people so they you know
they like got I don't know we were like
on a beach and then they threw us a
football and they're like play football
and all the other models were like
playing football like in a pretty way
you know like and that me I was all of
the photos I've got a red face covered
in sweat my nostrils are flared like at
one point a girl yells get her away from
me
birth control confusion so I was like
hormonal I fell on my face I forgot to
thank the director so I was just like
what does it all mean nothing madness
madness madness and he stuffs the
middlegame he's like what and I realized
I had lost my mind and I said I just
said never mind